as I'm 1020 alright okay so next talk is
buy some options we'll talk about min
estimation okay thank you all for coming
and thanks very much the organizers for
their efforts so this talk is going to
be about a very simple problem how to
estimate the mean of a random vector so
the problem is the following you get to
see n samples you know X 1 up to X and
their D dimensional and their iid copies
of some unknown random variable X and
your goal is just to estimate the mean
of X based on these samples no of course
probably everybody's thinking like why
don't you just use the empirical mean
and move on with your life and indeed in
many situations the empirical mean is a
good estimator of the population mean
but but the best estimator to use
depends on what you want out of your
estimator so let's review the most
classical picture maybe the the the
first thing you might want is that your
estimator have small mean squared error
this expectation will always be over all
the samples unless I say otherwise so
maybe you would like your estimator to
have small mean squared error and then
if you assume pretty mild assumption
that the variance of X exists the mean
squared error is minimized among all
possible estimators by the empirical
mean so that's a good choice and in the
classical picture we even can say
something about how the under this weak
assumption we can say something about
how the empirical mean fluctuates about
the population mean at least in the
asymptotic sense if we know that the
number of samples goes to infinity then
central limit theorem say that the
distribution of mu bar the empirical
mean becomes Gaussian in this talk we're
gonna aim for a more fine-grained
picture in two ways one is that we will
ask for confidence intervals we want
estimators for which we can prove radii
of bounds on radii of confidence
intervals and we're interested in non
asymptotic bounds okay so more precisely
for every what we would like is that for
every number of samples and every
desired confidence Delta we would like
to give an estimator mu hat of the mean
such that we can prove a concentration
inequality like this edema deviation
found on the distance of new hansom you
with the smallest possible our Delta and
our Delta here plays the role of the
radius of a Delta confidence interval
but in high dimensions so here's the
picture in case you've never seen a
confidence interval before you know
here's here's the population mean of
some data here's my estimator and I've
won the game in this case because I
decide our Delta was this radius radius
ball okay and of course confidence
intervals have also been studied for a
long time so what can there possibly be
new to say um it turns out that
confidence intervals and the empirical
mean don't play so well together when
the underlying distribution this random
variable X has a heavy tail and today's
talk will be all about heavy tailed
distributions X and that's why this this
talk makes sense in a robustness
workshop we're going to ask for
estimators for which we can prove the
kind of confidence interval bounds on
the previous slide under the mildest
possible assumptions on X that we can
get away with and the assumption for the
rest of the talk is just that X has two
finite moments okay so that's what I
mean by heavy tails for this talk and
just to get you in the in the mindset
here are some distributions that you
might keep in mind so in blue we have a
standard Gaussian that does not have a
heavy tail always moments exist in green
is another Gaussian it has higher
variance that doesn't make it have a
heavy tail but I'm thinking of this may
be modeling a data set that has some
kind of corruptions in it and you could
think of corruptions whether adversarial
or you know just introduced by some
nasty noisy process as as introducing
heavy tails into your into your data set
and then an orange is the the canonical
heavy tail distribution the Pareto
distribution or power law and you can
see it's outgrowing gaussians very
quickly okay so I made this claim this
so far qualitative claim that the
empirical mean has poor confidence
intervals poor means too large in heavy
tailed situations so let me try to make
that a little bit more precise you know
the intuition here is going to be that
if you have a bunch of samples from a
heavy tailed distribution and you're
interested in what happens with
probability one minus Delta if you want
something to happen with probability one
minus Delta you cannot rule out that the
list of samples has some egregious
outliers some vectors of say very large
norm they're very far from the mean and
these vectors will really destroy the
empirical mean because the empirical
mean is quite sensitive to such outliers
so let's I know this is familiar ground
but let's just review what's going on
so to state some quantitative bounds on
confidence intervals achieved by the
empirical mean here some of the just the
main players that will appear in them
Sigma is always the covariance of X for
at least the first half of this talk and
the two key quantities are the trace of
Sigma which is the expected squared
distance from a single sample X to MU
think of this as being a dimension
dependent quantity okay so if the data
if X is isotropic which is a good
setting to keep in mind then this is
like D the ambient dimension and here
the the norm of Sigma will always mean
the spectral norm or the maximum eigen
value so just to ground ourselves let's
recall what would what would be the
radius of a Delta confidence interval if
the underlying distribution X were
Gaussian okay this is like the best
possible situation and here the
empirical mean as an excellent estimator
of the mean so this is this is our kind
of reference point and here it turns out
you can you can this is a pretty easy
exercise you can see that the radius of
a delta confidence interval has the
following form it has an expectation
term and a deviation term so notice that
the dependence on Delta lives only in
one of the terms and the qualitative
features the important qualitative
features of this or the following one
okay it has a 1 over square root and
convergence rate not too surprising
second because X in this equation is
Gaussian the dependence on the tail
probability is logarithmic in 1 over
Delta and the amount you pay in the tail
is dimension independent it multiplies
only the top eigen value of the
covariance instead of the trace of the
covariance that's to contrast the
situation it with the empirical mean in
a heavy tailed situation so under the
assumption of only two finite moments of
X if X has only two finite moments the
best you can hope to do to bound the
confidence intervals of the empirical
mean is chebyshev's inequality and
you'll get a
like this so again it has the one over
root N rates not too surprising but it's
much worse in its dependence on Delta
you know the dependence first of all
became polynomial in 1 over Delta
instead of log 1 over Delta and 1 over
Delta multiply the dimension dependent
quantity trace of Sigma so this leads to
the question is there an estimator of
the mean whose confidence intervals are
as small as those achieved by the
empirical mean in the Gaussian setting
but under only the assumption that X has
two finite moments so is there an
estimator of the mean which is that
robust the answer to this not due to me
appeared up this is actually the
culmination of a series of papers by a
lot of folks up here in a paper by
Lugosi and Mendelssohn earlier this year
unfortunately the estimator proposed in
their paper the the best algorithm we
know to compute it by and whereby best I
mean with respect to running time is
really slow it seems to take exponential
time in the ambient dimension so this is
bad news in a high dimensional setting
so the main results of the work I'm
talking about answers the following
question is there a polynomial time
computable estimator whose confidence
interval radii match those of the
empirical mean from the Gaussian setting
even when the underlying distribution
has only two finite moments the answer
to this is yes according to this paper
actually I should say in some
late-breaking news I received an email
last night with some some small
technical difficulty in a part of the
proof that should follow from standard
machinery that that Jerry and Adam
talked about on Monday so take that for
what it is I just haven't had time to
address that in the archived version yet
but anyway that would be the main
theorem in this work
so other questions thus far you're
nodding like maybe you have a question
but maybe not okay so the two moments
are being at variance I mean it variants
that's it yep yeah I'm actually going to
pay a constant factor in the in the
radius the two terms will be separated
but eat but both will be multiplied by
some large constant yeah
and I don't know what the right call I
mean I know what the constants are you
get for this algorithm but I don't know
they're certainly not the tightest
constants you could hope for okay so so
let me describe a little bit of prior
work obviously estimating the mean has a
long history so we can't be totally
comprehensive here as before we are
talking about submitting the mean of a
distribution whose covariance is Sigma
you get n samples you want confidence
one minus Delta and there are three
kinds of confidence interval radii which
are going to appear I'm gonna call a
good a good radius as this this thing we
saw from the Gaussian setting so it has
the separate has the dimension
independent tail with logarithmic
dependence on Delta there's they're
gonna be tail bounds of this form
there's I'm going to call them okay they
have the sub Gaussian tail the log 1
over Delta but the rate of that sub
Gaussian tail depends on the dimension
it multiplies trace of Sigma and then a
bad a bad confidence in already assess
what you would get out of the empirical
mean in a heavy tailed situation so
here's here's just a few things to
compare to as we discussed you there's
the empirical mean which of course is
polynomial time computable in any
dimension but it's confidence interval
radii are not so good it turns out that
in one dimension there are a lot of
estimators that we know that under the
assumption of only two finite moments
achieve good confidence interval radii
and they're polynomial time computable
about five years ago some some ideas
were introduced that allow you in high
dimensions in polynomial time to get
this kind of sub galaxy and tail but
with a dimension dependence in the in
the rate of tail decay and then this is
this work by Liu Gaussian
from early this year that give a really
slow exponential time algorithm but it
has exactly the property that we want
it's got a good tail and it works in any
dimension and then the main theorem of
this work is an algorithm I'm calling
median SDP it works in any dimension it
has this good tail rate and it runs in
polynomial time yeah so what is the
death does that you would be interested
in practice that's a good question
I don't know and actually I was going to
just yeah I was gonna say something
about this at the end of the talk um
it's not clear that you can distinguish
like I don't know if you can distinguish
these rates in practice right because
Delta has to be seems like it has to be
really tiny also the first in the Rocky
patients use 5% that's a fact of time so
that's if you want to estimate if you
want to estimate one vector right then
then you would be losing a factor 10 if
you want to simultaneously estimate many
vectors and be able to pay for a union
bound then then you might want much
higher confidence on a per vector on a
per vector basis right and you can
imagine you know somehow it's not so
hard to imagine situations where there
are a lot of high dimensional vectors
I'd like to estimate so I at least want
why would I would at least want to be
able to think of Delta as decaying with
with D because I should think of
estimating an umber of vectors that's
comparable to maybe the dimension that
they live in whether or not you should
think of Delta is decaying so fast that
you can tell the difference between
these rates like is it exponentially
small indeed maybe that's more of a
theoretical concern in that at that
point I'm not sure yeah
time yeah slow polynomial time but slow
like and and yeah input size to a big
constant ten at least I don't know
something big I don't think that's
inherent by the way the the one of the
features so this is this this algorithm
is going to use this sum of squares
method so most weres method is really
nice forgiving clean and simple proofs
that polynomial time algorithms exist
but usually to obtain algorithms with
really attractive running times you need
to do some additional work you need to
simplify the algorithm maybe remove some
of the sum of squares type machinery so
I haven't tried to do that I think it
should be possible and I think it should
be possible to achieve even nearly
linear running times conceivably other
questions yeah so the empirical mean
doesn't depend on Delta to the rest of
these estimators depend on Delta yes
they do
maybe there are some here that don't
maybe somebody more educated than me
knows the answer but but these certainly
depend on Delta and as does I just
meeting there's to be and I think I
think it's knowing that to get this kind
of rate you need to depend on Delta you
can't have a have an estimator which
that's not true there's somebody's
shaking their shaking you can use the
same Gaussian rates or heavy-tailed
distribution okay I didn't know that so
I should say I'm a I'm not mention my
I'm you know computer scientist by
training so I'm sure many people are
more familiar with the statistical
literature and I'll be very happy to
hear to go saying the exact same thing
to get this behavior you meet your
estimator to use Delta in vain so this
is this is a literature question so
let's let's take it offline so we can
move forward but the answer is yes with
the exception of the empirical mean all
of these things depend on Delta ok so
here's here's the theorem for every
number of samples every ambient
dimension every desired confidence
there's an algorithm with this running
time this this hidden constant as I said
is maybe like 10 which given n samples
from X produces an estimator such that
this
pound holds so this is the Gaussian rate
and we're paying a constant in front of
it and as I said I don't know what the
optimal constants are and I don't know
whether the optimal constants
information theoretically should be
achievable in polynomial time or not
open question
okay the yeah sorry the main innovation
technically sorry wise aren't lining up
there we go the main innovation
technically is a new SDP approach to
computing a high dimensional median this
semi-definite program is based on the
sum of squares hierarchy that we heard
something about on Monday but I want to
emphasize that familiarity with SOS is
not a prerequisite for this talk and by
making some judicious simplifications
later on we're going to talk only about
semi definite programming and it's more
basic forms in a technical part of the
talk so you can stay awake questions
about the theorem statement anymore
before we talk about how it works okay
so here's the agenda for the second half
of the talk I want to describe what
happens in the one dimensional case I
want to describe this an idea called the
median of means estimator which maybe
some of you in the audience have seen
which is going to underlie the rest of
the estimators described in the talk and
then I want to discuss how Lugosi and
Mendelssohn generalize this meeting of
means idea to two high dimensions and
finally describe something about the the
SDP based algorithm okay so let's talk
about one dimensional prim one
dimensional mean estimation you get n
iid copies of some random variable X its
expectation is mu this is now a number
and it's variance is Sigma squared as we
said under only these assumptions the
empirical mean will achieve this kind of
confidence interval radius
it'll be polynomial in 1 over Delta and
I want to describe an estimator which is
she is a confidence interval radius like
this so the 1 over Delta in Hema log 1
over Delta and the cost is that some
hidden constant got a bit bigger here so
the hidden constant is probably one in
the first thing so here's the estimator
inwards unpick in it'll be in pictures
on the next slide take your samples
randomly partition them into K buckets k
take K to be some constant times log 1
over Delta step one we want to get a 1
over root n convergence rate and the way
we're going to do this is just take the
empirical mean of the samples in the
buckets and in step two we're going to
output any median of the bucketed means
median of means
so here's the estimator in pictures take
a bunch of samples here I put them into
I think ten buckets at random and
plotted the means in the buckets and
then in green you can see the median of
those pink dots that's your estimator
why does it work why does it replace a 1
over Delta with a log 1 over Delta if
you get nothing else out of the talk
remember this insight the number of
outliers in a list of heavy tailed
samples concentrates even when the sum
of outliers the sum of the outlier
values doesn't some of outlier values is
very nasty because it's you know a bunch
of big numbers but the number of
outliers concentrates much better so
here's
here's the formal argument in
one-dimension it's ultra simple remember
we took these bucketed averages right so
we took our samples we bucketed them we
took the means and we can think of z 1
up to ZK which are these bucketed
averages as independent draws from some
other random variable whose mean is the
thing we want to estimate and whose
variance is a K over N factor smaller
than the guy we started with that's just
because averaging reduces the variance
and there were n over K samples per
bucket and the first observation is that
it's at least let's say 2/3 of the Z
eyes are not outliers in this sense for
some number R that I'm going to choose
later the distance from Zi to MU is at
most R then the median is also close to
R ok and this is just because you know
if you have a set of 2/3 of your samples
the median has to be like either
contained in that set or sandwiched
between two points in that set so if
there aren't too many outliers the
median is good so now we'd like to know
how how small can I make R so that this
thing happens with high probability so
you get that to happen I first need to
get some kind of control on an
individual Zi and the only hope that I
have is to use chebyshev's inequality
because all I know is about the second
moments of Z and chebyshev says this for
any radius for any number R the
probability that Zi deviates more than R
from the Mew is at most the variance
over R squared which is this number and
now what I'm going to do is choose R so
that the probability that any individual
Zi is an outlier is like 0.01 notice I
don't need high probability bounds on
any individual Z that would kill me
because he has a heavy tail but once I
know that no Zi is individually an
outlier with more than point zero one
probability I know that the probability
that there are say more than K over
three outliers is exponentially small in
K that's just a binomial tail bound
because I chose pay to be log 1 over
Delta what I'll get is that with except
with probability Delta this condition
holds where R has chosen to make this
0.01 and the result is that with
probability at least 1 minus Delta the
median of Z 1 up to ZK these bucketed
means as distance at most square roots k
Sigma squared over N which is
square root Sigma squared log 1 over
Delta over N to the mean questions about
this where do I go to okay oh great
that's cool that's very good
um okay questions about this in that
case
great so now what are we going to do to
generalize this thing to higher
dimensions this was a one-dimensional
picture and we saw how to get 1 over
Delta to become log 1 over Delta
remember that now in high dimensions our
goal is an estimator with this kind of
confidence interval radius we're going
as before let's let's just let's just
try to do the simplest thing we can so
we're gonna take our samples x1 to xn
we're gonna put them in buckets as
before we're going to take the empirical
means in the buckets and we're going to
think of these bucketed averages as
themselves independent draws of some
other random variable Z whose mean is
the guy we wanted to estimate now this
is a D dimensional vector and whose
covariance is reduced by a factor of K
over N from the guy we started with now
what could you do the question we need
to answer is what kind of outlier events
can we ensure hold with probability with
with high probability in K remember
because I chose K to be log 1 over Delta
this will get me like 1 minus Delta
probability and in the one dimensional
case we were able to say that with high
probability at least two-thirds K of
disease are not outliers where the
definition of an outlier is distance
more than a constant times the square
root of the variance to Mew if I try to
do the same thing in two high dimensions
I will get in trouble I could say let's
let's let's just prove the same theorem
where I do chebyshev as before to
establish the meaning of an outlier and
I'll get the following kind of bound
kind of result with high probability at
least 2/3 K of the Z's have l2 distance
at most the square root of the thing
that plays the role of the variance or
the variance of this distance to the
mean and the problem is that this
distance this this expected the variance
of this distance is dimension dependent
this is this will be like the trace of
the covariance of Z which will be like a
K over N factor times the trace of the
covariance of Sigma and if you push this
kind of idea through if you try to say
their moat they're say you know K over 3
of the Z's which are outliers I don't
care about them and then I'm going to do
something simple with the remaining
two thirds K Z's he will tend to recover
estimators with this kind of dimension
dependence of Gaussian rates they'll pay
Trace sigma times log 1 over delta where
as we want our tail to be dimension
independent so this idea this this
straightforward generalization won't
work
in high dimensions if you want the
optimal kind of rate Lugosi and
Mendelssohn proposed the following way
around this
you can't ask you just can't ask for
two-thirds of the Z's to be in liars if
you try to wear at least where the
definition of in lier is not too far
from the mean and l2 if you do you're
going to have to pay too large a
distance to the mean so instead they
proposed to change our perspective on
the notion of in liars and outliers
instead of any individual Z being an in
liar and or an outlier . we will talk
about in liars and outliers on a
Direction dependent basis we will look
at one-dimensional projections of the Z
1 to Z k-means and then we will ask in
each direction which guys are outliers
and which guys are not so here's some
manufacturer data set with let's say
population mean here and you could
imagine that if I project this data set
on to UM under this direction that the
points in red form outliers right in the
points in blue they're still pretty
close to the mean whereas if I projected
in this direction the Senate outliers
changed now these points in red form
outliers
so what does this by you
here's the estimator that Lugosi
Mendelsohn proposed again they take as
input a bunch of samples they compute
these bucketed means Z 1 to Z K and then
as output what they will do is find a
vector X which has minimum maximum
distance to a median minimize over all
the choices of X the maximum in any
direction hair Direction always means
for me a you know unit vector in Rd of
the distance from X projected in that
direction to the median of the Z's in
that direction this absolute value it's
not I think you can put absolute values
there but you can also just think of
swap swapping you for - you use might
get a different set of outliers so ok
so as an alternative interpretation or
maybe the same interpretation if the
maximum value of this optimization
problem turns out to be our using our
because it will be our confidence
interval radius then our estimator mu
hat as a result we'll have distance at
most R to a median to being a median in
every direction so um here's the picture
here's some here's some candidate X now
I'm not saying this is the best X this
is some candidate X we might be
evaluating to see if it's R if it's a
good estimator and if I project in this
direction I need to pay this distance to
a median whereas if I project in this
direction okay the median change this
guy is certainly no longer a median in
this direction but this guy is and I
need to pay this distance to a median so
we'll try to minimize minimize the
worst-case distance I need to pay to a
median over choice of this black dot
okay this is a bit of a wall of text but
this is really the beating heart of
Lugosi and mendelssohn's estimator so as
before you bucket that you take your
samples you put them in buckets
you take your means in each bucket and
then they prove the following results
this is the this is the big thing if you
choose R to be a big constant times this
sub Gaussian rate then with high
probability probability at least 1 minus
Delta for every direction there are most
K over 3 outliers according to the
population mean if you pick the
population mean as your points you will
see that projecting in every direction
there are not too many outliers and
furthermore this at this parts an
exercise to prove any two points that
have this property
yeah sorry
thank you that's a typo yeah this should
be CIU
sorry what did you say new you yeah new
you thank you yeah thanks a lot
so furthermore if you have two points x
and y which share this this property you
know if you know that but for both x and
y this holds Y u plus R you can conclude
that X minus y actually I think this is
another typo it should be 2 R okay and
you do this by just saying that if you
look in the direction from X to Y then
there must be a shared in liar both both
x and y must have an N wire in that
direction you can compare their
locations to that in liar okay
unfortunately so now this suggests an
obvious estimator right just um find any
points
yeah suppose I told you our although you
could minimize over R suppose I find any
points which in every direction has a
small number of outliers sounds like
it'll work according to this lemma but
how on earth would you do this
algorithmically right
so the main contribution of the of my
work is a convex relaxation and an
analysis of it of this optimization
problem which you can see is the one
that I just described for this Lugosi
and Mendelssohn median and so minimize
overall choices of X in Rd and all radii
are the radius such that for every
direction you there at most K over three
Z's that form outliers
according to X and the philosophy in the
construction of this semi definite
program which follows this sum of
squares method is that you use an SDP
which has enough variables and
constraints that every step of Lugosi
and Mendelssohn's analysis every step of
their proof of their lemma also goes
through for to analyze this SDP right
this is surprising that you can do this
you can imagine that Lugosi and
Mendelssohn if you reinterpret their
their results you can imagine it's
arguing about integral solutions to this
optimization problem right we'll take a
convex relaxation of it but our
relaxation will be sufficiently strong
that whatever properties of integral
solutions Lugosi and Mendelsohn are
using also hold for relaxed solutions
right and of course you know if you had
enough constraints you can always do
this the non-trivial thing is that you
can capture enough properties of the
integral solutions using only a
polynomial number of extra variables and
constraints so this is kind of this is
kind of the core of this proof stew
algorithm sum squares method that Jerry
and Adam talked about on on Monday and
the sum of squares framework it gives
you some some technology to add these
add the right constraints in a
principled fashion so you don't have to
cook them up all by yourself setting
this SDP up is actually a little bit
cumbersome for a talk so I'm going to
switch to discussing a slightly simpler
problem that's going to capture most of
basically all of the main ideas in the
SDP relaxation of this so first time
yeah you have a relaxation
the relaxation isn't tight but do the
bull text the value of the relaxation is
also an acceptable value mark that's
exactly right yes yes the value of the
relaxation is acceptable value of our
and okay I didn't tell you but you need
to find some way to take a you know
solution to the relaxation and actually
extract an estimator this turns out to
be trivial there's no no interesting
rounding you just read it off of the STP
okay so if I yeah other questions about
this because then I'm gonna switch to a
simpler problem I have like five ten
minutes is there right cool okay so
let's talk about a simpler problem I'm
gonna change notation I'm gonna throw
out the samples X I don't care about
them anymore we're certainly we're gonna
take them we're gonna bucket them we're
gonna use the empirical means in the
same in the buckets so now let's talk
about a random variable Z it has mean mu
and let's say it has covariance Sigma so
this is a change of notation from before
and I'm gonna be interested in a
slightly different problem which I'm
going to call certifying the median so
the problem is the following I'll give
you the vector Z 1 to Z K and I will
give you AR and I will give you some
candidate point X right an RD what I
would like you to do is certify and I'll
say what this means in a second that X
doesn't have too many outliers in any
direction
what does what is certification this is
kind of a CS theory concept that I'm not
sure has totally made it over to
statistics so here's the idea I want an
algorithm that takes this input and the
other outputs yes or I don't know if the
output is I don't know then you don't
that you didn't learn anything about
your about about the inputs but if the
output is yes then the algorithm there's
a guarantee probability one nope no
probability here if the output is yes
then there is a guarantee that there at
most K over three outliers in any
direction according to X right and the
goal is that this certification should
succeed that is output yes with high
probability over Z 1 up to ZK if I
choose R at this this turns out to be
the right
Gaussian rates if you if you go back
through the bucketing and figure out
what how the covariance has changed okay
so you can imagine that what's happening
is we're saying let's solve an easier
problem I'll tell you the mean right now
I just want you to check that there
aren't too many outliers and even this
doesn't have an obvious polynomial time
algorithm because you have to check
something in every direction of RT so
just as an example if I told you this
data set and I told you this point and I
told you this distance R you would have
to output I don't know because there are
too many there are too many outliers in
this direction as centered by this point
but if I told you the point here which I
didn't make a picture for you you could
say yes so let me describe now a semi
definite program you should say yes you
should yeah yeah yeah you should say yes
and we hope that you are able to with
high probability yeah that's right so
the the at the first step the first step
will solve this right if you can't just
use a median of X you had like by taking
these empirical means in each bucket you
guarantee that the population mean is
close to the median hence we can discuss
an outline - okay
okay since I don't have too much time
let me describe what this STP looks like
and then we'll wrap up so like like like
every classical SDP it starts with a
quadratic program here's the quadratic
program it has some some variables that
represent a vector in D dimensions and
it has some variables which I'm thinking
of as zero one which represent out
lioness okay and the goal will be to
maximize overall directions and choices
of these 0 1 variables well this just
enforces that the variables are 0 1 and
this enforces that you're a unit
Direction maximize overall you're at 0 1
choices the number of outliers in this
direction right if I set bi to 0 then
then this inequality is vacuous but my
goal is to set B eyes to 1 because I'm
trying to maximize this and if I set bi
to 1 it says that that Zi is an outlier
in the in the U Direction sorry they
should probably be X because I want this
to make sense given any point and now
like usual you'll take this quadratic
program you'll think of rank 1 solutions
to it which would have the form
concatenation of B you concatenation of
B you transpose this is like ad plus K
dimensional vector and we'll relax it to
some block PSD matrix so it has a block
that represents that's a proxy for BB
transpose a block that's a proxy for uu
transpose and then off diagonal blocks
and the resulting SDP will look like
this maximize over block matrices like
this guy the trace of this part that's
like my objective function subject to
the constraint that on diagonal in the B
block the values are at most one that's
capturing this that's a relaxed version
of the zero one constraints the trace of
the you block should be one that's a
relaxed version of this constraints and
if you think of the I throw WI as a
proxy for be I times u which is what
shows up in this quadratic program
constraints you'll see you'll wind up
with these relaxed constraints so is it
the SDP if there are there questions
about it otherwise I'll say two lines
about the analysis and then wrap up
go so what's our what's our goal we want
to say that in every direction there at
most K over three outliers assuming I
make I make a good choice for the value
R and we would like for this to happen
with high probability this is critical
this is how I'll get log one over Delta
tale dependence the proof of this comes
in two parts there's an expectation step
and a concentration step and both of
them use non-trivial properties of the
the SDP as compared to more naive more
naive kinds of high dimensional medians
so the first step is to show that the
expected value of the SDP expectation
here is over Z 1 to Z K is it most let's
say K over 6 some constant less than K
over 3 and to do this the proof relates
the SDP value to a norm of a random
matrix this is a pretty standard way to
analyze an SDP except often when we
relate the SDP value to a familiar
random familiar norm like the spectral
norm of the covariance of the Z's or
something like this in our setting that
won't work because I can't get control
over the empirical covariance I just
don't have enough moment control on the
Z's and so we're saved in this step by
being able to use a more robust norm
than one might usually use to analyze a
semi definite program we can actually
use a two-to-one norm of a random matrix
and then we use growth and dekes
inequality to relate the SDP value to
the two-to-one norm so we can I'm happy
to discuss this offline now there's a
concentration step which which I think
actually is maybe the more it's the
simpler but maybe the more interesting
um part of the proof our goal is to show
that the SDP concentrates around its
expected value with with really nice
concentration exponential tales and the
reason this holds is because the SDP
picks up on the fact that moving a
single Z I as far as you like can only
introduce one more outlier okay this is
a this is a property that the SDP has
which would not be shared by norms or
averages of the Z's which would be which
wouldn't satisfy a bounded differences
property but we can show that the the
SDP value satisfies a map about
differences property and therefore we
get exponential concentration about its
expectation so this is kind of a recap
of what I just said a common strategy to
analyze semi-definite programs is to
especially in this kind of estimation
settings is to control their values by
using eigen values of nice random
matrices matrices form from your input
from your samples unfortunately the most
standard kind of things to do won't work
because you can't control even the top
eigen value of the covariance so the
empirical covariance but the SDP can
handle less outlier sensitive norms by
growth and ikan equalities the SDP can
handle norms that only look at say the
first moment of disease instead of the
second the second point is that unlike
norms averages and other kind of
analytic quantities the SDS DP values
can satisfy bounded differences and
that's this means that SD peas can offer
you high probability guarantees in
settings where averages like empirical
mean would not so the in conclusion the
main theorem is the first polynomial
time estimator that achieves sub
Gaussian rates in the heavy tailed
setting in high dimensions and this goes
back to Andres question and another
question from earlier in the talk the
algorithm I described is most certainly
not practical it is it answers the
question is there a polynomial time
algorithm for this problem but it
doesn't go beyond that so you might
first ask whether this algorithm can be
made practical and the next question you
might ask is because of the subtle you
know there's not that much difference
for reasonable values of Delta you might
think in the tail rates of this
estimator versus the slightly less good
ones that are dimension dependent
there's a there's a question of whether
you can find a practical estimator with
empirical performance that outperforms
the dimension dependent estimators which
are really fast in practice like
geometric median okay that's all thanks
very much for your attention
[Applause]
[Music]
and emissions random matrices involve
the energy analysis for a generational
problem to meet the are they're still
nice like they have like horribly
dependence on trees in etc no no no no I
mean the the the only thing you actually
need to do if I'd had ten more minutes I
could show you the analysis of the whole
thing you really just show get the SD
p-value steep DP of Z 1 to Z K you bound
this in terms of the two to one norm of
the matrix whose rows are the samples
are the means of a bucketed means so the
2 to 2 norm of this matrix would be the
top top eigenvalue of the empirical
covariance or the square root of it I
guess to discuss instead of the original
problem oh yeah yeah no different no
different that's this is all you need to
also channel also for the original
problem
the press I have one question so can you
explain briefly why you said that you
have to use SS 4 for the original
problem yeah good good question um I
should say I don't know that you have to
it's what it's what happens kind of for
Tecna at some point you just say well
it's throwing as many constraints as I
feel like I need today but yeah the only
reason is that if you want so here I'm
thinking about the problem where I was
told you right if instead you're also
searching over X's you just got a degree
three polynomial here so you know if you
want to use the SOS framework you need
to throw and get to degree four just so
you have a well-defined relaxation I
think you can probably avoid most of the
degree for SDP you wanted to third of
the D is to be good
Oh 2/3 2/3 is just a number bigger than
half oh what will turn out to matter is
that um like so you can show that that
that the for this part of it you can
show any kind of any quantile is good
that doesn't matter you just kind of
lose in losing the constant in front of
the rates you need the quantile to be
bigger than half because you want to say
that eventually the guy that I find and
the ground truth mean have a shared in
liar in the direction between them right
so you look at the direction between
them you say here's my guy here's here's
the mean and there's some Z which is not
too far you know it's lies between them
in this projection right so that I can I
can get a handle on how far I was from
the mean so then okay
the covariance midgets and a special on
was founded first moment like a shark
which our country that's a good question
I believe that it can we actually
haven't haven't finished proving that
we've thought about it but I don't I
don't know the answer yet all right so
this thing SEM again
[Applause]